on va plus loin avec gedimat directeur
du mensuel afrique magazine bonjour j
adore face à vous gauthier rybinski la
rédaction de france 24 bonjour bonjour
vautier c'est en ce moment même à
l'élysée emmanuel macron réuni une
trentaine de dirigeants africains et
européens pour évaluer la situation au
sahel l'heure on l'a bien compris et au
retrait de l'armée française du mali
écoutez ce qu'en disait le porte parole
du gouvernement il ya gabriella talent
dans un contexte très dégradé au mali
avec la prise de pouvoir par une jante
le refus d'appliquer un calendrier de
retour à l'ordre démocratique qui avait
pourtant été annoncée et le recours à
une milice privée russe ce n'est pas un
sujet franco-malien vous le savez le
retrait français du mali la fin de
l'opération barkan pourrait faire
l'objet d'une annonce demain gauthier
oui en marge donc du sommet union
africaine union européenne ça ne fait
guère de doute ce qui est beaucoup plus
problématique c'est de savoir dans
quelle mesure cette opération barkan va
se redéployer et où sachant que comme le
dit le porte parole du gouvernement
français si les conditions ne sont pas
réunies eh bien on ne va pas s'établir
là où ces conditions ne sont pas réunies
c'est à dire c'est très vaste les
conditions qui ne sont pas réunies ça
peut être une mauvaise gouvernance ça
peut être un sentiment qui français très
prononcé alors bien sûr on parle du
niger on en parlera tout à l'heure mais
manifestement 7 ce retrait est ce
redéploiement l'opération barkan est
voulue par la france comme étant quelque
chose autre 2e de général d'un ce que
dit gabriela talent ça n'est pas nouveau
et ça n'est pas strictement français le
but étant par dessus tout de séparer
cette espèce de face à face en chiens de
faïence entre la france et ses anciennes
colonies et donc d'invoquer le la
généralité ou plutôt la puissance du de
l'europe et de sa de sa culture et de
ses valeurs pour justifier ce retrait
conclusion logique à z lui même de moins
de surenchère jusqu'à l'explosion de
l'expulsion par nom de l'ambassadeur de
france l'histoire aurait pu s'écrire
différemment quelle conclusion vous
tirez vous de l'opération barkan non je
pense que c'est une opération qu'il
faudra lire avec un peu de recul dans le
temps
la première phase étant celle qui a
permis de sauver l'état du mali donc
période françois hollande la deuxième
phase c'est l'installation et la
reconquête ou la stabilisation du nord
la troisième phase c'était la
redirection vers des opérations plus
ciblées l'implication des européens
progressive il ya eu plusieurs phases on
peut difficilement en tirer un bilan
aujourd'hui en ce qui est sûr c'est que
ça a bloqué
en partie les incursions djihadistes ou
dans tous les cas le allez dire le le
rouleau compresseur qui aurait pu
descendre du nord vers le sud est con on
a ouvert un front après on n'a pas réglé
le problème après il ya eu un certain
nombre de deux on n'a pas réglé les
problèmes économiques on n'a pas réglé
les problèmes sociétaux on n'a pas réglé
le problème institutionnel du mali qui a
eu un premier coup d'état puis un
deuxième puis un troisième
certes on a mis sur le dos de barkan et
on a mis très franchement sur le dos de
la france des choses qui lui échappe au
départ on est vraiment dans une
opération de protection militaire et
c'est devenu le néocolonialisme le post
colonialisme et c'est ce qui explique
aussi que dans tout l'est dans tous les
débats maintenant sur le reprofilage de
l'opération française mais qui va pas
être que française ça c'est assez clair
aussi je pense maintenant je pense qu'on
parle d'une opération franco européenne
avec aussi il faut jamais le les alliés
la france ont pas échaudés on a vu avec
l'expulsion des danois du mail échaudés
ils sont échaudés ils sont prudents ils
font attention mais on n'a pas changé le
problème le problème c'est que sur toute
une bande encore une fois qui n'est pas
que le mali mais le mali c'est le point
central est le point faible c'est toute
une bande qui va de l'atlantique à la
mer rouge en descendant jusqu'à la forêt
équatoriale il ya une question
sécuritaire djihadistes qui est posée
qui impacte plusieurs pays et donc la
sécurité européenne elle est directement
concerné c'est pas à 50000 km c'est à
l'autre côté de la méditerranée s'il ya
des avions il ya des gens qui peuvent
passer il ya des attentats il ya des
intérêts français certes mais il ya
aussi des intérêts je rappelle que on
parle rarement de l'allemagne mais
l'allemagne est devenu le quatrième ou
le cinquième partenaire de l'afrique
dont il ya du business il ya des gens il
ya des communautés donc c'est pas une
affaire extra européenne c'est une
affaire européenne sauf que pour créer
ce mécanisme
c'est complexe c'est ça va mettre du
temps comme des à gaultier où est ce
qu'on va s'installer après juste un
point je cède la parole ça va pas on va
partir du jour au lendemain ces rondes
et plasma de 1500 hommes d opter du
matériel donc ça va prendre quelques
mois donc d'une part on va dépasser
l'élection présidentielle française et
deuxièmement il peut se passer plein de
choses pendant ces quelques mois y
compris au mali donc il peut y avoir des
ajustements
j'allais dire dans le temps sur le
périmètre de la nouvelle opération
c'est l'ampleur du défi qui a changé
gauthier jah press par la force des
choses des éléments qui échappe aux
français ou bien une mission dont on a
perdu de vue l'objectif au fil du temps
qu'elle est est il d'ailleurs cet
objectif stopper l'avancée djihadistes
éradiquer tout bonnement la menace
terroriste en tant que telle ou bien
garantir un pouvoir démocratique à
bamako
cette mission marque n elle avait les
yeux plus gros que le ventre
manifestement c'est à dire que l été
après c'est le serval car ap les hyades
quiconque ni qui consistait à contenir
la pression jihadistes vers le sud du
mali ça a été ensuite oui de créer des
conditions favorables à l'éclosion d'une
gouvernance vertueuse de créer aussi la
l'implantation d'un état malien qui
aurait pu finalement assumé ses
prérogatives dans des régions où il l'a
déserté et tout ça par une opération
militaire et donc avec en plus une
ambiguïté d'emblée c'est que cette
opération barkan faisait face à des
injonctions contradictoires de la part
des populations c'est à dire que elle
était là bien sûr pour combattre le
terrorisme mais lorsqu'elle n'appuyait
pas ou lorsqu'elles n'étaient pas
capables d'installer ou d'instaurer
d'autres des méthodes de gouvernance on
lui reprocher et quand elle ne vous
n'arrivez pas à attraper les djihadistes
on l'utilisé et on lui dit toujours
c'est bien la preuve que vous êtes
copain avec les djihadistes pour vous
emparer de nos richesses et de rien
faire contre cela et ne rien faire
contre la présence djihadistes à veut
dire aussi que d'une certaine façon les
maliens on le voit non pas il n'avait
peut-être pas à profiter de cette
aubaine mais n'ont pas profité en ce
sens que l'état malien s'est reposé sur
cette opération barkan et n'a jamais
cherché par exemple à étendre ses
prérogatives dans le nord par exemple où
l'a finalement on a commencé à constater
une sorte de faveur accordé parfois aux
jihadistes non pas sur leur sur leur
présence et idéologique mais sur le fait
que parfois ils assumer la sécurité des
civils sur place ce que ne faisait pas
l'état malien le redis on va peut-être
juste écouter le président nigérien
mohamed bazoum puisque on lit maintenant
le redéploiement passe notamment par le
niger écouter ce qu'il a à dire est aisé
de voir agir juste après
nous sommes dans une relation
normale avec la france
vous tous les pays
ce soir il avait à nos côtés dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme aujourd'hui
la phase est le pays qui concerne le
plus de sacrifices
la relation sera différente la situation
sera différente au niger ou bien il faut
aussi regarder ce qui s'est passé un
convoi français a quand même été attaqué
en fin novembre entre le médecin et le
niger si vous voulez
d'abord il faut on peut parler de la
france encore pendant des heures mais
c'est aussi une affaire africaine sert
qu'à un moment il faut aussi qu'on voit
ce qui ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
franck que des hommes politiques que une
opinion qui est usé par des années
d'attentats et c'est que des petits
malins
qui en mal de notoriété popularité ou de
putsch dit c'est la faute des français
ok très bien c'est la faute des français
c'est pas vrai c'est pas la faute des
français les français on peut leur
reprocher plein de choses on peut
reprocher même un certain néo
colonialisme dans le business dans
l'affluence la françafrique est pas
morte évidemment il ya eu des
maladresses évidemment tout ça c'est
très clair mais la réalité c'est que
c'est un problème de sécurité africain
les les mouvements jihadistes sont des
mouvements sahélien implanté dans le
désert la faiblesse institutionnelle de
certains états et la faiblesse militaire
de certains états a accentué le
mécanisme est donc la france est venu
avec ses troupes en essayant
d'embringuer d'une part les européens et
aussi il faut pas oublier la présence
des onusiens pour essayer de créer un
cordon sanitaire mais c'est un passage
vers le problème et locales
deuxièmement sur l'euro dispatching je
pense que c'est en discutions je ne vois
pas un bar can be sous un tableau kbis
installé aujourd'hui ailleurs dans les
mêmes périmètres le troisième point qui
est très important c'est les pays de la
côte on voit bien que derrière tout ça
ils sont la cible désignée que ces pays
vont devoir investir un certain nombre
de points de pipe dans leur défense
c'est à dire que quand on va diminuer le
réseau barkan on va augmenter la demande
de défense d'un certain nombre de ces
pays donc ceux qui ont des moyens je
pense à la côte d'ivoire vous aussi au
sénégal pourront s'organiser pour
augmenter leurs dépenses militaires mais
il faut aussi qu'on arrête de dire à ces
pays faut rester dans les 3 % faut se
battre contre le changement climatique
faut lutter contre l' qu'ovide et puis
en plus vous allez lutter contre les
djihadistes et en plus à l'est nous
aider pour soutenir les transitions
démocratiques dans le sahel tout ça pour
rien sans un rond depuis des mois et des
mois c'est à dire on a dépensé excuse et
financière aidant plus militaire est
passé les 2 c on peut pas claqué en
europe et aux états unis 2500 à 3000
milliards de dollars aux 4000 milliards
de dollars pour lutter contre le co lead
et dire à des pays africains qui vont se
retrouver en première ligne ou qui sont
en première ligne
excusez-moi démerdez vous avec vos
moyens il ya ces saisines adéquation et
j'espère que demain
et ce soir et demain ce c1 c'est une
opinion qui va être un peu exprimés quid
gauthier de l'avenir des casques bleus
l'armée française au frais jusqu'au lac
ce qu'on appelle une réassurance à la
minus ma c'est à dire en fait une forme
de protection aérienne alors selon ce
qu'on sait après jusqu'à présent cette
protection ne devrait pas être remise en
cause là où ça va être remise en cause
c'est qu'à partir du moment où la france
va se retirer de d'un certain nombre
d'unités comme barkan elle peut aussi se
retirer des casques bleus et là ça pose
le problème effectivement aussi par
exemple des britanniques ou des
allemands qui sont parfois casques bleus
par rapport aux intérêts commerciaux de
leur pays et le fait qu'ils seront face
par exemple à contenu de leur mandat un
qui est amanda restrictif qu'ils seront
face est évidemment pas parfois 60
seulement à des djihadistes mais aussi à
des comment dirais-je à des mouvements
de populations qui sont et c'est ça qui
me paraît le plus intéressant qui sont
formellement réfractaires à ce que
peut-être la démocratie ce qu'on a vu au
burkina faso c'était lorsqu'il ya eu ce
putsch vous avez eu des des gens qui
descendait dans la rue pour clamer ce
putsch et non pas pour défendre le
régime civil et ça ça me semble quelque
chose je la joue tout simplement à ce
que disent les hyades sanaa n'infirme en
rien ce que vous disiez sur la question
des fonds mais ça me rappelle ce qui est
arrivé quand laurent désiré kabila est
arrivé au pouvoir au zaïre qui est
devenue la rdc c'était le fameux qu'est
ce que c'est que la démocratie
j'en sais rien et c'est pas intéressant
c'est un concept qui vient de l'occident
et ça j'ai l'impression que c'est en
train de ressurgir danser dans ces pays
dodu du sahel séparer je pense qu'il ya
quand même une part comme je les dis je
pense une profonde frustration et une
usure il faut quand même imaginer que
d'une jolie à l'inefficacité
kaboré faut quand même rappeler que
kaboré a été élu tout à fait normalement
pour un deuxième mandat il ya eu une
campagne politique née des élections
tout à fait ouvert et donc y avait pas
un problème de légitimité le problème
qui s'est posé c'était la capacité dans
le cas du burkina ou dans le cas du mali
de la capacité institutionnelle de ces
pays à générer du développement et à
générer de la sécurité militaire et
alors et ça il n'y arrive pas mais on
peut pas espérer non plus des miracles
absolue on n'a pas affaire à des pays je
rappelle le cd pays qui on peut appeler
émergents mais qui dans la réalité sont
des pays encore pauvre avec peu de
moyens et qui sont sur des étendues de
territoires qui sont immenses il
faudrait des drones des satellites il
faudrait un matériel de dingue pour
surveiller tous et tous ces quatre
cartes et ses pick up qui rentre et qui
soit et c'est vrai comme disait gauthier
y a des liens d perméabilité entre les
populations c'est vrai que lui être en
malice et ne plus contrôler non plus la
zone des trois frontières c'est ne plus
encore une fois je ne pense pas que ça
sera laissée à l'abandon je ne sais pas
comment ça va se réorganiser mais ça va
se réorganiser
par contre les maliens vont se trouver
face à la difficulté d'assumer leur
propre défense ce qui est quand même
complexe et je suis pas sûr qu'un
bataillon de mercenaires russes réglera
le problème que qu'on n'a pas réussi à
régler par ailleurs même dans le nord
par exemple dans le nord
merci azima merci également à gauthier
rybinski c'était on va plus loin place
au focus à présent direction la pologne